foreign
for the Press preview it's our first
look at the front pages and tonight I'm
joined by the journalist and author
Rachel shabby and the associate editor
for politics at the Daily Telegraph
Christopher hope they'll be with us from
now until midnight a very Happy New Year
to both of you we'll chat in a minute
we'll have a look at the front pages uh
first of all though starting with the
times Millions will shun trains forever
reads their front uh page as they said
generation of passengers will be put off
train travel due to recent strikes while
the eye reports that the NHS faces three
months of turmoil amid long weights and
shortages
the mirror leads with the same story its
headline future of NHS is on a knife
edge the Ft leads on economists
predicting this UK recession will be the
deepest and longest yet
while the Daily Mail looks at comments
made by Prince Harry about the royal
family its headline Harry I'd like my
father and brother back and the Daily
Telegraph has this same headline as it
reports that the Duke of Sussex has
claimed the king and Prince of Wales are
unwilling to reconcile with him
as you can see it's also the front of
the sun I want dad and brother back and
pine dining reads the front of the Daily
Star
and don't forget by scanning the QR code
that you can see on the screen join the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us discussing them and I'm joined
tonight by journalist and author Rachel
shabby and Associate editor for politics
at Daily Telegraph Christopher hope
great to see you both as uh what we're
all preparing to go back to work kids
preparing to go back to school after the
festivities are over and boy doesn't it
feel like the decorations have come down
the fun has ended and uh the the misery
continues really especially when it
comes to the NHS Rachel the front page
of the eye NHS faces three months of
turmoil some are predicting it's going
to be much more than that
absolutely and we've had some really
Grim stories about the NHS over the last
few days
um with with reports that sub between
300 to 500 people are dying
um due to lack of access to accident and
emergency which like other parts of the
NHS and social care is completely broken
and it's you know we we all rely on the
NHS and most of us have people in our
Lives who are elderly and vulnerable and
the thought of them not being able to
get the care that they might need should
anything heaven forbid happen to them is
is absolutely terrifying and that is
exactly the situation that so many
people up and down this country are
facing we're hearing all kinds of grim
reports from
um doctors and nurses and Frontline
workers ambulance workers
um about the the desperation of having
people wait in ambulances for you know
12 to 8 out 18 hours because a e is
backed up or you know lying in their own
urine because they're waiting for beds
to free up at a e and outside of a e
there is a critical shortage of Staff of
beds of funding and of social care and
it is absolutely crippling uh the NHS
system which which we all believe in and
we all want to support but the
government does not seem to be prepared
to give it the funding and the
investment that it needs right now yeah
I mean of course the government would
say it's giving up to 14 billion
additional funding over the next two
years and an extra 500 million uh pounds
to to speed up Hospital discharge and
free up beds Christopher But whichever
way you look at it 75 years old this
year the NHS and it's really showing
signs of its age what did you make of
those comments from the Royal College of
emergency emergency medicine today that
between 300 and 500 people a week are
dying as a result of of the problems the
NHS is facing I mean it's become a bit
of a political Hot Potato that figure
hasn't it
that's right it's difficult to
understand the chaos which is engulfing
all the NHS so it can maybe a bit
confusing to some viewers because last
week it was the nurses or early or
tuition the nurses going on strike this
is nothing to do with that at all this
is about the the overwhelming uh impact
of of of covid more serious cases flu
also overwhelming parts of NHS and we
seem to be on a kind of a loop of just
crisis more money new crisis more money
and we argue that Telegraph argues in in
our leader column tomorrow that it's
very it's time probably for MPS leaders
of all parties to get together to find a
new solution for the NHS now the the toy
party has seen the NHS as a live rail
not to go near not to touch since about
2006 when David Cameron came in because
much of the prioritization of the NHS
haven't under Tony Blair and a little of
it or not as much as labor happened
under the Tory party but I think I
wonder whether all this may go towards
some form of Royal commission to
consider the future of funding whether
you have a way for some people to pay to
pay for care to get professional access
others will hate that but that may be
the answer to try and get more money
into it or even charging for
appointments
um a low rate so if you miss an
appointment you get charged because the
missed appointments cost the NHS so much
whether this this model is fit for the
21st century I think is the new the new
idea I think we'll see in currency in
the first six months of this year
Rachel's shaking her head there oh we're
running short time Rachel
we'll we'll perhaps we'll explore that
further in the next hour if that's all
right because I just want to move on to
another story that's a hangover from
2020 to Prince Harry and his woes front
of the day Telegraph I want my father
and brother back Rachel is he going
about it the right way do you think two
more TV interviews in a book
well he obviously still has things left
to say and as you say he is giving he's
got a book out to promote and so he has
done uh these two TV interviews I think
are both coming out over the next few
days or on Sunday one is we're in the UK
with ITV
um and one I believe is uh in the US
with um CBS
that's right yeah so he's talked he's
you know trailing these these two
interviews and we've seen clips from
them
um and part of the discussion is around
how you know he he's part of the
institution the royal family but
actually what he wants to be a part of
is is this family that he is now
estranged from and sure I've no doubt
that on a personal level it it must be
very very painful for him uh and for
Megan to be so estranged from from this
family and and for him to be estranged
from both his brother and his father
Chris um from Pages Daily Mail as well
Harry I'd like my father and brother
back pretty much the same headline as
the telegraph what's interesting is the
Oprah Winfrey interview was was widely
seen as as not much of a grilling in the
sense that we know she's friends with
with the couple but Tom Bradbury and
Anderson Cooper uh a pretty hard-hitting
journalist I mean they're not going to
give him um an easy ride and actually
what what he says in those interviews
maybe more interesting than well
actually he says in the book
well yes we do dinner what's in a book
until next week
um I mean intrigued by the way how these
papers split you have the left leading
mirror the eye focused on the crisis
engulfing the and the times also looking
at an idea we'll see later about the
about um the trains but the the Chrysler
Public Services other papers trying to
change the subject The Daily Mail
they're talking here about Harry The Sun
Also talking about Harry we've gone for
Harry but I think people want to it's so
Grim out there trying to get back to
work tomorrow will be very hard with the
train strikes I think people want to see
other news that will maybe just is like
just not about the the chaos in the
country at the moment and I can see why
some people have chosen to go with the
with the Harry drama which will run now
all week daily will have more bits of
these two interviews being released from
ITV and CBS in America
um and I think you know I think um there
was a fit that we hear for the weekend
papers that there'll be lots of attacks
on on the Prince of Wales uh Prince
William when the book comes out and
here's Harry being consideratory he may
think that the book may go Miss maybe
Harry going early on the conservatory
message because he knows how bad the
book will be next week that's what I'd
worry about yeah and just quickly
Christopher do you think it's the right
approach by
um of the king and William to to stay
silent uh on all of this
I think that they've got to I think it
will just it'll bring him down to the
level of rang about he said he said he
said and she said what they said at the
same time and you get into a rare about
the record comparing the record I think
that's that's really not where you want
to be if you're the royal family I think
he is running out of ammo he can't keep
saying the same thing and keep making
money the hope is that this is really
the last Salvo from Harry and Megan
although there was rumors the weekend of
Megan write your own book which could
have a whole different uh uh level of
controversy but I think the hope is it
will go away I think that the the Harry
drama is something to talk about which
isn't about the public sector failures
at the moment and that's quite maybe
cheering as we try and get through this
difficult week okay a difficult week uh
when it comes to strikes as well
especially on the rails Rachel more
strikes tomorrow and again on Friday the
rmt uh staging two walkouts
um and millions will shun trains forever
according to the times and when we have
got used to not taking trains haven't we
joined the pandemic and is that a habit
that's going to stay
I'm really not sure about that look I
think this is just part of a broad
attempt we've seen over the last few
months in many of the newspapers and
including the times too basically blame
um the rail workers and the rail unions
for these strikes the trouble is that
overwhelmingly we have public support
for most public sector workers and it is
uh holding up for the rail workers as
well and we've just heard from the rmt
that actually you know they say the
government is holding up uh the
potential for negotiations there and the
capacity to reach a deal it's
interesting that in the polling so far
it does show uh public sympathies are
very much in line with that I.E they
overwhelmingly blame uh the government
plus uh the rail companies rather than
the unions for the strikes and I think
we're going to see this as a problem
going forward with all the public
sectors strikes the problem being that
the public sympathy is very much with
public sector workers particularly
coming out of the pandemic where we you
know have this intense feeling of
gratitude forged for such workers from
health workers to postal workers but
also we're all in this same cost of
living crisis so really when the
government and the papers are attacking
uh Strikers striking workers they're
actually attacking all of us uh Chris
how long do you think public sympathy
that Rachel was talking about will will
last if these strikes Carry On and On
into into the year
I'm not sure it's even there as much as
Rachel says I think that the the nurses
are the most politically difficult group
to oppose for the government I think on
this issue with the with the rail unions
I mean people can see how you can't
afford to pay these large pay increases
um I'm hit by the strikes tomorrow in my
last train back from London tomorrow
afternoon is five o'clock five fifteen
I've got to make arrangements to work
from home I can because I'm a journalist
other people can't it does hurt people
it hurts people across the border you
know emergency service workers uh can't
get into work if they commute uh
tomorrow evening I mean it's gonna be
hard all this week in in London of
course around the country there are
other strike action as well um I'm not
sure this idea that there's there's um
sympathy for some of these Strikers is
is there
um I do think though that um that this
method's messaging here to the times is
probably right people will think well
they'll give up on trains I find trains
very convenient but um if the trans
services are reliable you make other
arrangements that will increasingly
happen all right Christopher Rachel
thank you both for the moment we'll chat
again in a second coming up after the
break warm weather hits ski slopes as
snow dries up we'll take a look at that
story after the break
[Music]
hello again Rachel and Christopher are
still with us Rachel front of the
financial times I think it was um I
think it was the CBI wasn't it the
beginning of December said we were
heading for a short and shallow
recession but according to the Ft
they've spoken to more than 100
economists and it's a it's a different
story
that's right this is a pretty Grim story
to start the new year where they have as
you say spoken 200 UK economists
um asking them for forecasts for the
year
um and they show that uh the UK GDP is
shrinking
um just at a faster rate and the
recovery is slower in 2023 so
um they spoke to one Economist who said
well look the UK GDP is shrinking by one
percent in 2023 compare that to the
Eurozone where um it's shrinking by just
0.1 or to the US which has growth of
0.25 and that's come from a report from
census economics it's also done a sort
of and into polling across this range of
economists and the words that they've
come up with for 2023 are Grim miserable
Bleak and tough and what they've pointed
out is that the recovery in the UK is
going to be slower in 2023 because of
policy choices from the government so
that's ranging from brexit or the
particular kind of brexit we've got as
well as
um not properly funding public services
so they're saying that the blame for
this slower and longer uh recession is
down to government policy choices
essentially yeah
it does what make Grim reading
but it does a very serious reading well
it doesn't say though I do know this is
a personal issue of of the chance of
Jeremy Hunt is that the reason why we're
we're lagging behind the EU this year is
because we are first out of the
lockdowns last year so apparently if you
take a a two-year average of the G7 and
we're second behind Canada so that it
what it doesn't say in this article
anywhere I can see is that it is
actually linked to the UK emerging
quickly and faster from the lockdowns
early in 2022 further than and quicker
than the other
um advanced economies Rachel is that not
a fair point
it doesn't say that in the piece I know
well I know I know it doesn't but I
happen to know it is the case or
certainly is the case this is Jeremy
Hunt said so well because he's he's all
the so actual some work on this
internally
okay all right okay well we can discuss
that more as well uh in the next hour
potentially that's on the front page of
the Ft just want to finish uh with this
story I mean this isn't going to
um well many won't have much sympathy I
guess with people who are going on a
skiing holiday this year but for skiers
we've had the last two holidays canceled
uh Christopher um the fact that there's
uh snow melting and conditions are
pretty poor is going to be a bit
depressing
yeah very I mean I think I think I'm
right and saying that Rachel and I are
not great skiers I certainly am not I'd
stick my bum out and do a dreadful
snowplow turn John I'm sure you're sure
you're much better than us Jonathan at
skiing but anyway yes skiing is not
great with the with the melting snow in
the Alps and it it's very sad if you
like skiing I know that when we were
locked down over the past two years
there was heavy snow in the Alps which
no one could ski on so it's completely
tragic
um and for people who are spending money
on going out on holidays and hoping to
ski this week
um in the last week of the of the
Christmas holiday is so sad they they
French are saying it's as bad as Easter
they're seeing lots of people being
admitted hospital when you have people
slipping over on slush and hurting
themselves and they're really even
Wheeling out um mountain bikes if you
look at the the main spread picture
there in the times you'll see a ribbon
and snow down the middle which is like a
road and either side it's green
um
um a verdant hillsides where they're now
deploying mountain bikes because they
can't ski on them it's a great shame and
it's a further reminder about climate
change and why that really matters yeah
I mean there are there are records being
broken again Rachel Switzerland had the
warmest New Year's day on record in some
results temperatures at 15 degrees
Celsius at Christmas week the second one
was on record in France
yeah it's absolutely incredible I mean
yeah I do not know how to ski but
absolutely this points to a wider
problem of you know this at the times
and other newspapers are reporting that
actually it looks like you know ski
holidays are going to become a thing of
the past but as you say there's a wider
problem here it's unseasonably warm so
there isn't enough ice or snow on the
Alps to begin with and then in the
summer it's melting way faster than it
should or then is normal and so the
combined effect is really quite
devastating and so this is part of a
wider picture we're looking at
um it will be ruining an industry
um in in those areas where there are ski
holidays but also globally we are
looking at increasing frequencies of
storms droughts hurricanes floods crop
failures we really are in serious
trouble
it is very concerning isn't it as we
start 2023 this snow machine is going to
be
busy